[Music]
this is star talk sports edition neil
degrasse tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist and sports enthusiast but
i'm not enough to hold this show i need
my co-host gary former professional
footballer in the uk hi nielsen welcome
back to the show dude thank you yeah and
how long have you been in the united
states
um depends who you ask i think it ranges
from two to two the real the real
question is how long have you been here
legally
i have always been here legally so okay
that's that's the good news and that
other voice popped up chuck nice always
good to have you man always good to be
here i just want to say absolutely
nothing i was delighted to host your
family for the weekend and when we did
one early morning you asked me for a
jump rope you went over to the side and
you worked out with a jump rope and i
was so impressed by that only to then
realize you never really did any sports
your whole life
yes um however double dutch is a sport
is that in the olympics we're going to
see that in paris yeah i think double
judge requires three people
chuck
you can't double dutch with yourself
that's how good i am
so gary what do you have in store for us
today okay this would be interesting if
not fascinating ten pin bowling they say
right but bowling
to get a perfect game means you score
over 300. which is regular you said 10
pin that's just regular bowling right
that's 10 pin bowling as opposed to
crown green bowling which is done on
grass and all the others
there you go so if you have an average
over 200 it's considered as an accurate
indicator of a misspent use
right
it's also
it's also an indicator that this person
may well understand more physics than
you think imagine right yes they're on
the lane with the ball in hand you're
discussing euler's equations of motion
whilst chewing the fat about radius of
gyration all whilst wearing some
dang ugly shoes that don't fit too good
and it's actually said chuck and you'll
love this if you learn to read the oil
patterns in the lane
you could find yourself with the cheat
codes for a perfect game and we must get
into how that can work out for us i love
it yeah i mean i haven't played
i haven't bowled
in many many years primarily because
it's become a place where yuppies go to
drink
it used to be you know like
i used to be in a league saturday
morning you went out you bowled it was
great now you can't get elaine cause
it's a bunch of yuppies sitting around
day drinking well is yuppie still even a
word is the language oh they they're
still they're still around i know they
still exist is it a word you're right no
you're right you're right you're not no
no neil you're right they're not yuppies
anymore they're hipsters oh okay
yeah i'm sorry i got it yeah they're
hipsters okay so gary who who
who do you have
who possibly has this kind of expertise
well surprisingly enough he's a guest
who's been on before we knew him as yes
dr dave the pool hustler he's now going
he's going to return today as dr dave
lord of the lanes
um because he he has some serious chops
he's bought a perfect game he has he
still has an average over 200
and you know what even i could work out
he was the guy to talk to okay
dave welcome back to star talk
thanks neil it's great to be back oh my
gosh i love quote dr dave i love that
just
it's just it's it's affectionate it's
more affection than just dave you know
dr dave so you recently retired
professor emeritus you don't look that
old at colorado state university got
your phd in mechanical engineering at ut
austin and i met my wife at ut austin by
the way uh the woman who would become my
wife and
you you've got your own youtube channel
and
facebook page dedicated to pool we knew
that but also to billiards so so you're
the man
you demand and so let me ask you
in your misspent childhood how did
polling become part of this as well
well my my early life dream was to be
the doctor dave of bowling instead of
the doctor day of a fool
because
yeah i grew up i basically grew up in a
bowling alley my my mom worked at a
bowling alley and luckily that bowling
alley also had a pool hall in it so we
just was just bliss heavenly bliss for
me even as a child
so which are you better at
um
i'm probably uh
people probably consider me a little bit
better in the billiards but but i'm a
strong bowler as well
what constitutes a strong bowler i mean
it would have to come down to the
numbers of your average yeah of course
what is the average that creates a
strong boulder anything over 200 like
gary mentioned is is considered strong
but you know i've averaged close to 220
i'm averaging about 220 right now partly
because i've got a brand new bowling
ball which we're going to talk about
later that's something boost my average
oh man that means you got the fingers
drilled for yourself
that's a good feeling
you take the ball and it's just a big
ball it's it's a sphere and you got to
go in and they drill the holes just for
you
it's so so dave uh in my uh engineering
physics classes i remember learning all
about sort of euler angles and
sort of the geometry of a rotating
coordinate system and my notes here tell
me that
uh euler
euler is a famous british mathematician
from a century gone by that you somehow
invoke euler equations to goal of 300 i
i you got to get me get me on that same
page here please
honestly i don't use the math when i
bowl but the math does affect the
physics on the lane
uh the euler's equations or oil oil did
many things but one thing he contributed
to dynamics is the euler's equations of
motion that describe gyroscopic effects
and these new bowling balls take
advantage of these gyroscopic effects
wow and i'm going to be very honest
because i don't care when i look
ignorant because it happens all of the
time
i i thought the oiler lanes
were
the greasy spots on the floor
i actually i actually thought maybe
there are slick spots
on the lane itself okay
e-u-l-e-r all you look i had no idea or
maybe oiler maybe orler was the first
guy that oiled the lane so they called
him the oiler right exactly
so it's euler eu lear okay yes so so
here's an interesting an interesting
observation and then i'll i'll pass over
to because because gary is is going to
drill you for the whole hour we got here
so
so
um what i remembered most about the
euler equations in my sort of
engineering physics was
normally when we think of something
rotating we think of only one axis and
so earth is rotating or or a top is
rotating that is spinning but if you
have
rotation
in more than one axis
simultaneously
then interesting things happen right so
so so here's the ball
trying to roll down the lane and so
that's an axis of rotation it's rolling
but then you put a little spin on it on
top of the rolling that's happening and
so the ball doesn't go in a straight
line it curves
so are you telling me you thought all
this out and you
and really really and it's not just
practice
well to play the game well it's all
about practice
but uh you know good bowlers take
advantage of the oil patterns which we
can talk about
and the boil
the ball manufacturers take advantage of
these gyroscopic effects see if you had
a homogeneous ball a solid sphere it has
holes in it but let's forget that for
now
and you spin it and you throw it down
the lane it's gonna spin on the same
circumference the whole way down the
lane
and this is actually uh this is actually
directly from billiards when we looked
at the massey shock a massey shot in
billiards is the same as a curveball in
in bowling
all right now if the ball is a sphere a
solid sphere when it's when it's trying
to curve it's spinning and uh coriolis
figured out that that the direction of
the friction does not change during the
curve
same thing in a on a pool table so what
that what that uh suggests is that a
stripe of oil is going to build up on
that ball along one circumference you
get a circle of oil building up on the
ball as it's traveling down the lane now
that's bad because the oil is slick well
he's good so he is literally talking
about oil chuck there is oil on the
lanes it's actually a petroleum product
it's not crude oil it's actually mineral
oil based but it's a very very clean
looking oil but it's it's slick
okay so
so chuck you were even wrong in your
ignorance that's pretty bad yeah well
you know
what can you say this is where i'm at
this is where i'm a viking meal okay
you got to be good at something okay
even if it's good at being wrong
dave so i mean we've got multiple axis
of rotation
and that's all happening but to drive
this apart from the bowler themselves
you've got a weight block inside now
they come in eight different shapes
and
they're not all asymmetrical they're
offset as well aren't they yes so how is
that then impacting on these euler's
equations of motion and uh how
how the ball does its thing
that's the critical piece here so again
if you have that solid ball that doesn't
have this weight block in it it builds
up the striper oil now the oil is not
consistent over the whole length of the
lane they put most of the oil at the in
the first two thirds of the lane the
last third is mostly dry it has a little
bit of oil that's where most of the
curve occurs in the last third of the
lane but if the ball is picking up oil
the whole way down the lane it's going
to slide more during that curve section
all right so these weight blocks it's
asymmetric
as neil's pointed out if you have a ball
you're spinning at about one axis
it's moving down the lane friction is
creating a torque or moment about
another axis
that causes this weird wobbling effect
the ball actually does this weird wobble
thing you can see me on video what i'm
doing but it gives you like different
circles of oil on the ball so that new
ball surface is touching the lane the
whole way down so it doesn't build up
oil on one stripe and when it hits the
drier part of the lane it has
has virgin virgin olive oil it has a
virgin oil-free surface to uh to help it
curve more so dave let me get if i
understand this correctly the first part
of the journey of the bowl is on oily
oilier
it's an oilier surface than the last
section
yes so
where it's oily you're not going to get
much friction to curve the path is that
correct bengal okay so
i always wondered
why the ball curve more in the last i've
seen this and i never understood why so
that's why it breaks hard it breaks
harder right yeah bowlers call that the
back end you want to have a strong back
end where it curves hard and and creates
a good entry angle into the pins which
we can talk about later also
if we've spent enough time and and sort
of examine bowling and come to the
conclusion that euler's equations and
motions are involved
surely now there has to be an optimal
speed an optimal angle of approach
because otherwise i'm sticking that
straight in the gutter
and we've got this configuration of pins
this triangular configuration and we've
all seen it what's it a seven and a ten
split where one the two furthest pins
away from each other are left and you've
got a spare to try and clear them up so
how do i get out of that by
using a bit of science by thinking right
there's an optimal speed there's an
optimal angle of approach or am i
daydreaming again no you're right on
right on topic let's talk about the pin
numbering briefly because i'm going to
refer to them at times so the pins are
in a triangle pattern the headpin the
one in front is called the one pin the
number it's so so surprising
right then the number this is surprising
too the next row is two and three and it
goes four five six and it goes seven
eight nine ten good all right so gary
just mentioned the 710 split that's a
boiler's a bowler's nightmare you have
the the far two pins in the corners uh
that you leave as a spare and it's
pretty much impossible to convert but
but it can be made mostly through luck
but let's getting back getting back to a
strike how does a bowler
give themselves the best chance of
getting a strike
you might think throw it right down the
middle
and hit that head pin right in the
center well that's the worst possible
thing you can do but that's what most
beginner bowlers try they try to throw
it in the middle i think a gutter shot
is worse than hitting the front i'm just
you know of all the worst things you
could do i'm thinking the gutter shot is
worse but
go on that's right
but if you throw it straight you want it
to hit off center slightly that's how
you can get a strike
but the problem is when it comes in
straight the ball deflects off the pins
a little too much and it doesn't have
enough power to drive through the center
and you often leave what's called the
five pin the one in the middle
or sometimes you'll leave a 10 pin
on the far corner because the ball is
not coming in strong enough to send the
other pins toward the 10.
all right so bowler they want to come in
at an exact six degree entry angle
all right this isn't random wow
extensive testing extensive testing lots
of simulation that was my problem i was
coming in at seven degrees the whole
thing and i was five and a half
you know neal that's your problem man
that's your problem seven degrees it's
not six it's nice oh oh my god yeah you
you were doing seven-minute abs
you might think a bigger angle is better
like you might think if i can get seven
isn't that better than six well at some
point it's coming into the into the pins
a little too steep and it just kind of
kind of tunnels through and doesn't
doesn't spread them as well so people
have found this six degree angle to be
kind of optimal it sounds like a small
angle but you have to curve it a fair
amount because it's only curving in that
last part of the lane and the lane is
really long and skinny so you get an
angle you have to curve it significantly
yeah and and is that the pocket that you
always hear them talking bingo for a
right-hander it's called the one the one
three pocket you're hitting the one and
three pins
at the first
and it's also called the manhattan side
you don't want to go to the brooklyn
side that's kind of embarrassing to a
good
[Laughter]
the bowler came from you know people in
manhattan they have to cross over the
bridge to get to brooklyn right all
right so now cross over because inside
the headpin you're hitting the left side
that means you weren't very accurate
you're hitting on the brooklyn side we
call it so is the gutter the jersey side
now
what's going on so what what if i just
get brute force and ignorance to start
bowling and just barrel one down there
is it would it just be simple enough to
just say it's velocity or are we into
spin rates and you know if i want to get
this angle of approach and we're playing
with a lane that isn't uniform from
start to finish
you bring up a good point because that
entry angle is critical but the other
critical thing is momentum you know the
weight of the ball and the speed of the
ball both contribute to the to the to
your pin action how well you
you bust up those pins
so if you can throw a heavier ball
faster it's going to help assuming you
can get that angle which is harder the
faster you throw it the more difficult
the more difficult it is to curve it
enough to get that angle
uh but if you can if you can spin a lot
so bowlers want a lot of rev rate
you know uh good bowlers top pros they
can they can spin the ball almost 10
revolutions a second so it's a pretty
fast spin yeah so you want to spin it as
much as you can so you can throw it as
fast as you can and still get that six
degree entry angle that's the that's the
secret sauce of bowling are you are you
saying that if a person is weaker
they have to use a lighter bowling ball
and all other things being equal they
will not be as successful at bowling
because they're using a ball with less
mass
now some pros you know 16 pounds is the
maximum allowed weight and for for many
years all pros use 16 pounders but now
they're migrating closer to 15
and you might think well why they're
giving up that that free momentum well
they can throw the 15 ball
15 pound ball faster
okay so they can actually get and they
can spin it more so it's a trade-off
between the kinetic energy of its speed
and the momentum you get from its mass i
guess there's
two of those
uh well again the main thing you want is
momentum you want you want mass or
weight and you want speed you want
here's something that i thought was
happening and maybe not and then we'll
take a quick break and we'll come back
and pick this up some more
uh does the spin they're picking up on
what gary said does the spin of the ball
other than altering its direction of
impact does it help
uh
knock a pin sideways better
rather than bowl it down forward
and help to create more sideways action
helping you get those side pins a little
better does that is that a thing
uh not really because most most most
bowling shots you have three three kind
of phases you have the slide phase which
is spinning like mad but sliding through
the oil very little friction it's
curving just a slight amount
then you have the uh the curve phase
where the friction is really grabbing
and it's changing the direction of the
ball and during that curve phase it's
actually losing that's the side spin and
when it's done with the curve phase it's
actually mostly rolling
mostly rolling in a straight line at the
desired angle at the end so it has very
little
excess spin left over when it's supposed
to forget that of course if you're
spinning it and it's responding to that
spin by friction it's slowing down that
spin of course
yes okay guys we got to take a quick
break but when we come back more on how
to bowl a 300
and 10 pin bowling on star talk sports
edition
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about
bowling
how to be good at bowling no how to be
perfect at bowling there is such a thing
as perfect ebola 300 and our special
guest today dr dave
alcitor did i pronounce your name
correctly sir uh right on right
for the french side of my family but the
italian side of my family likes
i'd way prefer that but i don't want to
offend the french side um dr dave we've
had you on before talking about
billiards and that was a fascinating
show one of my favorites and only to
learn that you have further expertise
because part part of your childhood you
grew up in a pool hall because your
mother worked there that that meant you
play
you grew up in a billiard hall which
also had pool tables but that meant you
you got free games that probably what
that meant oh yeah
so maybe you're good maybe you're good
at bowling because you played for free
not because you actually studied the
equations now fess up it yeah it can you
tell me i got a free ride neil you're
talking about man
confess your privileges here right this
is what we got to do so so tell me more
you mentioned this oil on the
you know none of us are thinking that
there's oil on the none of us
non-experts are thinking that anyway
could you just give us a little more
details about
why is there oil there and how you come
to exploit that fact and why don't you
guys just get a rad
okay well there is there is a former rag
in the automated machine that puts down
the oil this is a computerized machine
that puts the oil down
in certain patterns
and it's not always the same pattern
typically in a league situation they
give us a fairly easy pattern an easy
pattern is where most of the oil is in
the middle
and then the oil doesn't go down a lane
as far
all right that's the optimal situation
uh and one reason is if you throw the
ball across the oil like from the left
if you're right-handed you'll start to
the left a little bit if you throw it
across the oil
it goes out if you throw it out too far
it gets to the dry part of the lane
sooner and then it curves more right if
you don't throw it out far enough it
stays in the oil and slides
and that's how you optimize your chances
to get a strike you have strategy based
on how the oil is put down
you throw it out you mean the distance
between where you release the ball and
where it hits the wood
well that is one variable that some
people adjust but mostly i mean you're
throwing it more to the right if you're
right-handed
and you throw it more to the right it
hits the drier part of the lane sooner
and that left to curve sooner and you
can still get a strike you throw it too
far to the left it stays in the oil and
does it and doesn't curve as much and
you can still get a strike so you can be
sometimes if you're if you have your
optimal strategy for the oil pattern and
you're throwing it in the best possible
place you give yourself the widest
margin for error sometimes as much as
like six inches six to ten inches
you can be off by that much and still
get a strike and and how how much does
alcohol come into play
when making these
calculations mentally
well people that tend to get tense
alcohol is actually a
a booster because it helps them relax a
little bit
but that only works for to a point and
then there's there's a difference
between perceived and actual performance
chuck of course yeah yeah that alcohol
makes you makes you perceive performance
amazing right
you think you're clear clearly you've
been to one of my comedy shows that's
right so gary he's all yours gary all
right so i have to i have to imagine now
i'm bowling but the pattern of oil
that's been laid down in the lane isn't
fixed it's going to change that every
time a bowl goes down it so now i've got
an organic situation that's changing in
front of me so is it is it kind of like
a major cheat code once i learn how to
read the pattern read the oil movement
as balls bowls go down it and then
distribute oil in different places on
the lane
well there's three things there gary one
is you have to know what the pattern of
oil is you know they put down different
patterns on different different lanes or
in pro tournaments they actually put
down a different pattern on each of the
two lanes that they're bowling on just
to make it more challenging
and they have sometimes they use a
totally different ball enzymes they
stand in a totally different place and
throw it with a totally different speed
and direction on each of those two lanes
that's the ultimate challenge but again
in a league they're putting down pretty
much the same pattern for us every week
and you know i've learned to find the
optimal way to throw the ball to give
myself the best chance of getting a high
score
and how many balls how many balls are
you able to use if you're playing like a
real tournament game can you say okay
for my spares i'm gonna have a lighter
ball
or a heavier ball uh for my first throw
i'm gonna use a lighter ball and then i
have my second lane ball i mean are what
are there rules no there's no limits on
the number of balls you can use
in fact the pro they might have it might
sound ridiculous but they might have
like 15 to 20 balls at you know
available
and they might change balls in the
middle of a match you know if it's not
working out if they're really they're
reading something in the oil pattern
that that they didn't anticipate
so there's no limit on number balls
so imagine carrying a golf ball a golf a
golf bag a golf bag full of these
bowling balls around
wow
yeah but typically most league bowlers
they have like uh their their strike
ball their curveball and they have a
spare ball spare ball is usually made
out of a hard plastic that has very
little friction very smooth surface
even if you can and the beauty of that
is you can throw it your normal way that
you throw a strike shot which is your
most consistent throw
and it's spinning like like heck but it
just goes straight this doesn't go uh
to get that spare yes
so how do you know once you get to the
back end of the lane that you've got
certain things going on with the oil
distribution on the surface how how do
you how do you tell you know you you're
not allowed to walk down there and look
at it or can you read it from the way
the balls are moving
the last thing gary all right so let me
go back so first you have to know what
what the what the pattern of the oil is
that they're putting down then you have
to know how does that pattern change
uh over time as you throw balls because
the ball is picking up oil when it's
going down that slick part of the lane
and that oil is so so you're actually
removing a little oil from the first
part of the lane
and in that it's carrying that oil down
so as the night goes on as the games go
on and the oil is getting pushed down
the lane
and it's getting pushed in the area that
that your ball is curving all right so
it tends to give you less curve as the
night goes on in that area all right so
a good bowler has to adjust they can't
see the oil like you pointed out gary
they have to adjust based on what based
on the reaction of the ball
so when the ball is starting to come in
light we say it's it's not curving as
much we would typically move our feet to
the left
and aim a little bit to the left that
way we're hitting fresh oil and we're
hitting fresh dry lane down down the
last third of the lane yeah
so you've got to have a lot of
experience to be able to read
the oil patterns on the lane and then
have the knowledge to know what will
happen
but if they change this but you just
said they changed the oil patterns as
well
so just to make it in the middle of the
game they're just they start with
different starter patterns right what
i'm saying before the game do you guys
get to throw like how many practice
throws do you get to throw because
that's not fair you're starting a
competition
and you don't know what the terrain is
exactly we have to practice you know
even in the league they give us five or
ten minutes of practice and that whole
time i'm hunting around i'm hunting
around adjusting my speed adjusting my
spin adjusting my aim point to try to
find that optimal that optimal place to
throw the ball
in practice you have to identify that to
gary's point it's not that you can see
the oil at all times as the
tournament progresses you are reading
what is happening to the balls that are
thrown yeah and judging
what the oil distribution is in that
moment
a good player has to also realize did
that ball react like it did because i
threw it a little bit too fast or
because did i did i get a little extra
finger in it and spin it a little bit
too much but a good player is aware of
all that
and a good player also has to be
accurate enough
it's no it's no use for reading what the
ball does unless you can throw it in the
place you're aiming every time
you got to make the adjustment and can
you learn something from the way your
opponent is throwing it yeah yeah oh
definitely yes yes every every uh every
throw is information
concentration it's intense concentration
isn't it
oh you gotta just like any sport you
don't want to be too intense the whole
time you got to be focused and you got
to pay attention
and observe but you don't want to be
like you're not you're not super intense
staring the whole time yeah tell that to
tom brady
that's right
so there's a thing called the curveball
strategy which sounds like a baseball
term but it's not it's it's applied to
temp in bowling so is that a successful
strategy to cope with changing oil
patterns well yes we throw any good
bowler throws a curveball
to get that that optimal six degree
entry angle that's critical you have to
curve the ball to have the ball come
into the pocket at the good angle
and the amount of curve is affected by
the oil as oil changing and as oil
changes over the night you get that the
amount of curve changes and you're
constantly making adjustments
uh but you're right a curveball is
critical to bow well
i'm sure there's been some 300 games
from people that throw the ball straight
but it's very rare now these bowling
technologies like the the weight block
they put in the ball that that allows it
to get this gyroscopic effect that
prevents the oil from building up on one
stripe
one knows when that top and then when
that technology came out about in the
90s 1990s
the num the average uh the bowling
averages in leagues and the number of
300s per year increased dramatically
and you know so tell me exactly what
that is
what what is the blocking the block the
weight block yes so bowling ball again
is not a homogeneous sphere
if it were you would you wouldn't get
gyroscopic effects
and the ball would build up a a ring or
circumference of oil as it's going down
the lane and that would reduce the
friction when it hits the dry part
because it's spinning on this oil
so because they're inside the ball the
balls consist of what's called a cover
stock
it's usually an inch or so thick of
material on the outer part there's a
core inside of that that's a different
material usually harder
and then inside the core there's a
weight block and it's as gary mentioned
it's not always symmetrical it's it's
it's like a
uh generally the shape of like a little
football but it has sometimes it has
nodular shape it's they have they have
all these patented shapes that make
different manufacturers come out come
out with for marketing mostly
but they have different shapes that are
asymmetric and they're placed in the
core they're cast inside the core
in asymmetric directions and when they
drill your ball
there's a little plug that tells them
what the axis of this core is
so when they drill the holes they can
decide what angle to put these holes at
relative to the axis of the core and now
all that contributes to two things it
contributes to the gyroscopic effects
and it contributes to what's called the
radius of gyration which we talk about
we should talk about also i i can't help
wondering right because i don't think
ten pin bowling was initially
started knowing that you'd oil the lane
so a who came up with that clever idea
and b what happens if you don't oil the
lane
well that's great points gary yeah the
oil originally was to protect the wood
to treat the wood
and also to limit friction
all right because if you if you had a
totally dry wood surface well you end up
with a big rut in the middle of the lake
it'd be three gutters
the ball would be like a trench digger
exactly
uh so they first you know they
conditioned the lanes with the oil to
treat the wood and also to reduce the
friction so the wood wouldn't get
damaged too easily
um and in the early days people threw
the ball straight you know and then the
oil was there and then somebody
just like in just like in billiards one
day somebody put a piece of leather on
the end of the tip and then they were
able to put spin and then they started
this a whole new world of shots opened
up same thing with bowling somebody one
day said oh what if i spin the ball it's
going to slide through the oil and then
curve does that help me they didn't know
at first but through experience they
learned it helps a lot has there ever
been a bugs bunny shot where
they throw the ball but the ball doesn't
leave their hand and the ball
drags them down
you know funny you should say that
because as uh you know i live in
colorado and it's very dry normally but
i played in the tournament this past
weekend and uh there were a lot of
people on the bowling lanes and it was
getting a little warm my thumb starts to
swell you get a little humid and then
all of a sudden this the hole gets a
little it's a little sticky a little
snug
the ball stuck to my thumb uh
uh once and it it it didn't come out of
my hand until i my hand was way up in
the air and the ball went flying like 15
feet up in the air vertically and it
pulled me with me and i barely caught
myself see the problem if you could get
if you don't catch yourself you go
flying superman style and you'll land in
this oil you go sliding down the lane
okay so they can't handle that or you
just leave your thumb inside of a ball
we'd have to add another law to the
cartoon laws of physics to understand
what happened there well we're going to
take a quick break and when we come back
we want to learn more about
bowling fashions or rather
what's up with the shoes
what why
and and whose idea was it when
i'll just wear shoes that other stank
people wore just before being like who
came up with that idea and why
we're back star talk sports edition all
about tenpin bowling and the physics
of it
we got david alcitor
unknown to us
previously when we had him on before
talking about billiards that the man is
also a bowling shark and very impressed
by this
dave i want to pick up a point that you
started talking about but i want to i
want to ask a little more deeply you're
saying today the ball has three
components to it in its manufacture an
outer shell let's call it like my
analogy is earth's crust okay an outer
shell then we have a mantle a go inside
but in the core is a thing that's not
centered
it's off center so tell me what would
happen if i mounted the ball with on an
axis and then spun it would it just
wobble
is that what it would do
what's the consequence what's the
spinning consequence to the ball for
putting something in there that's off
off-center
yes
great questions neil
yeah so uh this asymmetry is what
enables the gyroscopic effects
all right and the asymmetry comes from
the shape of this core it also comes
from what angle do they drill the holes
of your ball it also comes from what
angle do you spin the ball about as you
throw it
so the ball is spinning about some axis
the ball has this asymmetry
friction is acting on the ball
it causes the ball to do this gyroscopic
precession or wobble or oscillating
rotation whatever you want to call it
and that that creates what's called
track flare the oil doesn't build up
under circumference the oil creates
these tracks that are flared out and
separated and when you get your ball
back after you throw it you can actually
see these oil patterns on the ball it's
called track flare and you can see these
different stripes of oil in the ball at
these weird angles all around the ball
oh my god that's why every time you
watch bowling on television which by the
way i never do okay but
because i cuz i have a life and you know
saturday afternoons for me are very busy
but um
but every time you see these guys
approach um the lane they have like this
cloth and they're it they're they're
like polishing their ball
which i had no idea why they did that so
they're removing the oil bingo they're
removing the oil you want i want that
to generate as much friction as possible
you also want your throat to be
consistent so you don't want to have oil
on it and have the oil build up over
time you want to get rid of that oil
i just thought they really liked those
i was like man that guy is proud of that
look at him he's just like yeah baby
it's okay daddy's got you baby daddy's
got you
and they want to shine it up so they can
see their pretty face in the reflection
so
knowing this is happening and the ball
the weight block is offset
i will now have to structure my
technique to bring the best out of that
particular setup on a ball so
it's always been a one-handed thing for
me watching bowling and at any time but
now it's it's
the the successful way is a two-handed
bowl which sounds a little bit like my
uh
mother would do to be fair
yeah the two-handed throw is actually a
fairly new thing and it's not it's
actually not widespread it is not new
yeah
chuck did it when he was a baby i was
gonna tell you that was invented by
three-year-olds okay
yeah next time
next thing you're going to tell me is
they put gates up over the gutters
[Laughter]
but so there's a there's something
called fingertip grip which now that is
something that is something a fingertip
grip is something that's that's
prevalent everybody any decent bowler
they don't stick their their middle
finger and index finger all the way into
the ball up to the middle knuckle they
only put the fingertips in or in the
span the span of the holes the
fingertips are much farther from the
thumb than the balls you would see in a
bowling alley the balls you can use the
fingers the finger holes are pretty
close together but any good bowler the
bolt the fingers are further apart so
you just part you just put your
fingertips in the ball the index finger
and middle finger fingertips then your
thumb that gives you a wider span and
when you want to apply spin those
fingers are the last things that come
out that the two fingers
index finger and middle does that mean
the holes aren't drilled as deeply then
that's right that's right
and so that gives you it's like you're
flicking the ball at the very end you're
kind of giving it a whip it's like a
whip effect on the ball okay so if the
holes aren't as deep that means the
balls are more symmetric
well the thumb hole's still deep
but
and yeah but when they drill the holes
in the ball it does create asymmetry
and but they when they when they these
weight blocks part of the issue is they
they put it off center slightly so when
they drill the holes it tends to balance
it a little bit
so that's that's kind of that's balance
but most balls are actually not
perfectly balanced
um but that's okay
but here's something in vegas
proper
dice
have
holes drilled for the numbers and
refilled with another sort of putty that
has the same density as the material
that they drilled out
so so the numbers are in white dots and
the dice are red typically right and so
so now there's no side that weighs more
than any other because of that if you
have dice where it's just holes and
that's it it's a non-symmetric dice
and it will not give you equal
probabilities and they go to extremes to
make sure those dice are balanced as
well not in my neighborhood they didn't
so
the question
dave the question we have to ask is why
do bowling shoes look like they've been
stolen from a 15th century medieval
festival
and then
who convinced us that i should agree to
stick my feet into somebody else's stank
feet that had been there right before i
arrived
and what is the incidence of athlete's
foot amongst bowlers
well luckily there's a bowling alleys
have a thing called lysol
they spray lysol in these shoes to help
help help limit that chuck
but answering gary's question why they
didn't say she
sprays it in to stop it he says he's
present to limit it i caught that you
caught that yeah yeah that's a that's a
very very important distinction that's
right
you know any any good bowler has their
own shoes obviously but yeah the general
population doesn't have their own
bowling shoes you can't expect that so
you have to provide them you have to
provide them and it isn't an awesome
gary that they look so retro cool they
don't look like medieval english stuff
they look like retro cool american dude
yeah that's what they tell them every
time i see them i'm waiting for richie
cunningham to come pop into your door
dave they've got there's got to be a
reason why you have to have those shoes
you can't just come in and bowl in your
own sneakers or something what is there
something special about these shoes
apart from the fact they look like
they're from the 15th century very
special the uh the part under your toes
is actually a piece of leather
that allows to slide more easily on the
wood surface on the lane
and the heel is actually more like a
rubber
all right and that serves as your break
it's not really sticky rubber but it's
kind of a hard rubber but if you try to
bowl like in tennis shoes or something
you're gonna you're not gonna slide
you're gonna stick and you might do the
superman thing into the oil you don't
wanna do that so you wanna you wanna
slide
in toward that foul line where you
release the ball and the bowling shoes
allow you to do that and the heel the
rubber heel let you put on the brakes if
you're sliding too much
wow so it's all about the friction just
the right am not too much not too little
friction exactly
now good balls they have a sense they
have a sense for we kind of do this kind
of instinctively using that heel like if
we're sliding too much we can kind of
sense that immediately we don't think
about it and then we apply a little more
pressure to the heel so it all happens
you know with experience you you take
advantage of that leather and that
rubber to control your slide optimally
because the surface gets dirty sometimes
those teenagers that throw the ball with
two hands chuck sometimes they they get
their sticky fingers all over stuff
yeah yeah and they get the lanes dirty
and that's that's why that's why they
shouldn't be allowed in the alley
i understand that you know bowling is
supposed to be a family sport but some
just for certain family members you know
but how about if you bowl while you're
still holding your beer is that
allowed uh no
in fact
a good bowlers don't like when you have
anything any food or drink in the lane
area you know you have to be in the back
you have to be back where the carpet is
you know and by the counter they don't
want you to have
yeah but there's lots of places to eat
and drink behind the line
yeah
and what about the pins dave because
they are getting brutalized every time
you throw a 16 15 pound ball down the
lane how are you ensuring that their
integrity is there because
they just i mean what are they made of
now are they still made of wood
well they were forever you know
bowling's pretty old it's like it's
literally thousands of years old
the egyptians had a form of bowling
all right and but for a long time it was
made out of wood and they were turned on
a lathe to give them that distinctive
s-shape
and the wood pins you know they they get
chipped they get cracked you know and
they have to be replaced you know fairly
often but nowadays they are synthetic a
really tough material
and the good thing about the synthetic
pens is they're more consistent you know
wood has grain and wood has different
properties in different directions and
on different portions but the synthetic
pins are more you know they're more
consistent and uniform and that's
probably contributed to the higher
scores over the years as well you know
if things are more consistent
and these machines that put down the oil
if they're better
if the if the machines that spot the
pins in the correct places are more
accurate with tolerances if all that
stuff is better then we can bowl better
and that's what's happened over the
years scores have gotten higher
how rare is a 300 how rare is a 300
uh well even league bowlers like myself
bowl three hundreds every once in a
while you know so um
uh this this past weekend i bowled uh a
279. i didn't ask about it
i had one shot where i threw it what i
thought was perfect yeah and i had
what's called a ringing 10 pin
the 10 pins the one in the corner and
the pin in front of that is the six pin
and if the entry angle isn't exactly
perfect that you don't hit in exactly
the right place that six pin just wraps
around the ten sometimes it touches it
and the ten pin just ringing in place
it's just wow
and that was the only mistake
i had all strikes except this one
ringing 10. so it's really ah that's why
they call it a perfect game i know if
you want to because you got it if it's
not perfect it's not perfect right so so
correct me if i'm wrong come here for
more so to bowl of 300 you have to roll
12 consecutive strikes exactly okay so
has anyone bowled two 300 games in a row
yes people have bald three three three
three hundred games in a row that gives
you a perfect series of 900. ah wow okay
so now based on that i'm just going to
say it ain't that hard
okay i'm just saying i've never heard of
a pitcher who's thrown three perfect
games in a row
now okay i think it's easy to getting uh
a hole in one in golf for example it's
easier than throwing a perfect game in
in baseball
uh but it's still hard it's still hard
so so for you uh so how many perfect
games have you bowled in your life only
one
but i've had many i've had many two
seven i asked you about the other games
okay
i know that's like saying that's like
chuck how many standing ovations have
you had well one time four people in the
back stood up
but then i saw that they were just going
to a concession stand
all right so here i'll break here i'll
make you feel a little better ready so
how many strikes in a row
had you thrown before it
and after it
so that we can now get the total number
of consecutive strikes that you've ever
thrown
yeah and oh
keep track of that we know we know what
that number is mine is 18. so i threw 18
strikes in a row yeah yeah very good and
one time i threw one time after 16
strikes in a row and didn't get a 300 in
fact
both games were like in the 250s or 260s
which is like
mediocre i don't get it how can you if
12 in a row is a 300 how does 16 not get
you over two games over two games
yeah like the last eight yeah the last
date of the first game the first date of
the second game
oh yeah right you know what that's like
chuck the baseball analogy here is where
you have multiple relief pitchers
combining to pitch a no-hitter right
that's what that is there you go you
staple it together
yes so yeah so no one pitcher gets a
no-hitter but they all sort of
participated so has it ever happened to
you where it's
the last throw of the game because the
tenth frame you just get three throws
yes but if you pick up the spare but has
it ever happened where on the
in the tenth frame the last throw you
screw up your perfect game
no i've never done that but that is very
common i have a friend who did that and
he got 2.99 that's it yeah you can get a
299 298 297. but if you miss if your
miss is somewhere in the middle of the
game you get a 279. that's the highest
you can get if your misses in the middle
of the game 279.
okay go back to the lane then you've got
the arrows because i mean the lane
itself is a series of
i don't want to call it points but it's
boards there you go and they all have
this little arrows in there and i'm
obviously they they're used as
guidelines are there any other kind of
markers on the real estate
that you can use to key off and get a
better strike
yeah there are other markers there's a
there's a row of little circle marks in
front of the arrows the arrows are about
15 feet down the lane and that's what
most bowlers use to aim
you know you want to be you don't want
to be gazing down at your ball or gazing
at the foul line you want to be gazing
at your distant target about 15 feet
down the lane so that's what most balls
are looking at they're trying to hit a
certain board you know between the
arrows there's boards you can actually
see the individual boards of the lane
there's uh five boards per arrow and
there's seven arrows across the lane
so there's uh
there's
35 yeah this this let's see there's
there's 40 there's 39 boards total
okay there's seven arrows but there's
two gaps on each side of the arrows
all right so yeah most bowlers are
aiming at a particular board the boards
are about a one inch wide
and some good bowlers can can hit their
target within about an inch fairly
fairly reliably
uh
two inches the pros are within an inch
you know league bowlers on me like me we
can get within two inches pretty
reliably the whole night we can hit our
target within two inches but if your
speed is off a little bit
if you throw it a little too slow it
curves too soon and you don't get a
strike you throw a little too fast it
curves too late
if you don't release your fingers the
exact same way you don't get the same
amount of spin so you don't get the same
curve so there's so many variables isn't
it amazing this this is almost i am
almost developing a healthy respect for
balling well thank you chuck because i
was i was uh i was perceiving a very
strong disrespect earlier
i'll tell you the truth
i'm going to be here i felt it too dave
i didn't like him dissing my 279s man
that's
oh god no this is i i have to tell you
dave that i think a lot of people suffer
from this bias
where
because everyone can go bowling people
are under the impression
that everyone can bowl yeah you know or
bowl well or it's not as difficult as
you just uh let us see which it seems
like it's a game of true precision but
at the same time this is the beauty of
bowling and billiards
you can you can be terrible and still
have a great time
that's what i love about billiards and
pool anybody can enjoy it it's a
beautiful thought has anyone tried to
sort of change the game
um make it more you know sexier more
interesting or is it as good as it's
ever going to get as we find it right
now
well like most sports and games we don't
want to change anything right in fact
these new balls that kind of
revolutionize the game and kind of
increase the scores a lot
you know purists don't like that
because it changes the game and then you
can't compare today's performance to the
past performance so we want the game to
stay the same but having said that
technology has changed a little bit and
technique has changed somewhat we we've
really mentioned the two-handed bowling
all right so most bowlers had their
fingertips in the ball and their thumb
in the ball but these two handers now
they only put their fingertips in the
ball
and they need the other hand to help
support the ball so it doesn't fall off
when they're about to release it they
have to help support it so they go down
the lane holding the ball with both
hands they have their fingertips in the
ball only
and when they release it they can put
way more spin on the ball because
they're not hampered by the thumb
everything's about those two fingers
that spin the heck out of the ball and
give it a tremendous well plus
your other hand can help spin it also is
that correct no the other hand is just
there for support to present they don't
use that because you know when you're
releasing the ball the other hand uh
comes off you just use the other hand to
get you to that release point then the
fingers do everything so how about this
because i just invented a version of
bowling in my head uh
which is you take
the hardest shots
and you
uh rank which shots are most difficult
and then the pin configuration you can
choose to get the most points so of
course the 710 would be worth the most
and you know uh the
one pin by itself would be worse
worth the least and then you can figure
out these configurations and then
you get to actually choose which ones
you will try in order to cr to score
more points interesting i like it
i like it yeah so basically each setup
has a different difficulty level yes
thank you thank you and if you get if
you get behind if you get behind the
game you can take on the more
challenging uh right right so you can
all you can always come back and win
depending on which level of difficulty
you choose uh uh to to roll your ball
i'm gonna give you a little credit for
that even though you disrespected me
earlier chuck i'm gonna say i'm gonna
give you some credit that's a good idea
man
i think you've taken the sport in a new
direction chuck dr dave it's great to
have you back and i'm i'm afraid to ask
you what else you are a world's expert
in yeah we might find that out on
another invite street dice is next three
times
chuck and gary always good to have you
man
it is thank you so that's a wrap on our
star talk sports edition
bowling
how to be an expert
know some physics
yeah
that's that's the takeaway from this
know some physics all right and have a
mom who used to work in a bowling alley
combine those two it's you're a winner
every time neil degrasse tyson here your
personal astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]